It may come as no
surprise that the Trump supporters
and I spoke with
really don't think
too highly of special counsel
Jack Smith or this investigation.
And if anything,
they're actually doubling down
on their support
for former President Donald Trump.
They see this indictment as further proof
of every level of government
and the press is the way that they see it
or going unfairly after Trump
like that is enough.
Former President
Donald Trump unapologetic.
And on the attack, Jackson
sounds so innocent.
He's deranged.
This is a political hit job.
Georgia's GOP convention
marking Trump's first public appearance
after becoming the first former president
to face federal charges.
We have one set of laws in this country
and they apply to everyone.
Special Counsel Jack Smith announcing 37
criminal counts
against Trump,
the majority
for violations of the Espionage Act.
Does it matter to me?
Not at all.
Outside the state convention,
his supporters are unfazed.
I think it's a bunch of
Trump ain't done that wrong thing.
Trump managed to save this country.
They're not going to let it stop.
They can't stand the fact
that he's running for president.
And I and I, Donald Trump,
think that it's probably altered.
But it's just typical, typical
liberal propaganda
None of the Republican voters
CNN spoke with had read the indictment.
No, I wouldn't
waste my time on a phony indictment.
I don't care about the damage
that you can.
You can indict abalone sandwich.
These loyalists
share a deep sense of distrust
against perceived opponents of Trump,
including the Department of Justice,
the FBI and the press.
Supporters routinely
brought up President Joe
Biden, former
Vice President
Mike Pence, and former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton.
All had sensitive materials
in their possession
while out of public office.
One big difference
Trump and his aide
Wanda face nearly a half dozen charges
related to obstruction
and concealment of documents,
including for allegedly
suggesting to his lawyers
to not cooperate
with a grand jury subpoena
and this whole fake indictment.
They don't even once mention
the Presidential Records Act.
The indictment outlines
two different occasions.
Trump allegedly
showed classified documents
to unauthorized people.
And in 20, 21 Trump admitted on tape
to having secret documents
that he hadn't declassified,
according to the indictment.
As president,
I could have declassified,
but now I can't trump said.
According to the transcript of the audio
obtained by CNN,
there's an audio recording of him
doing so.
We know that that can be changed.
We know that that can be altered.
Within the 49 page indictment, pictures
showing boxes of classified
documents stacked high
in a moral legal
bathroom, ballroom
office space and elsewhere.
What he did is incorrect,
absolutely incorrect.
But the system allowed it to happen.
The system is broken
and needs to be fixed.
The convention also drew a handful
of anti-Trump
protesters,
co-opting one of his
most popular catchphrases
in this quick moment of tension
locking his shirt
once again lock you up.
Hey. Hey. Do you support Hillary Clinton?
She doesn't like Roe.
You mean you're an idiot?
Ultimately,
these Trump supporters
could not point to any piece of evidence
that would cause their support to waver.
I think Trump is the best president
we've ever had.
And I'm all about getting him reelected.
And in a press conference
this past week, Special Counsel
Jack Smith encouraged people
to actually read the indictment.
It's 49 pages
long to get a full grasp
of the body of evidence there.
These Trump supporters
I spoke with made it clear
they have zero interest in doing that.
Meanwhile, Trump
denies any wrongdoing,
and an attorney for his aide
not a declined to comment.
Jim as well, Roseanne Barr,
thanks very much.
It's not his supporters
or some of Donald Trump's
allies up
on Capitol Hill
are also coming to his defense
Joining us now to talk about
this is Congressman Don Davis.
He's a Democratic congressman
from North Carolina.
Congressman, great to see you.
Let's listen to what
some of
Trump's Republican
loyalists are saying in reaction
to the indictment. I get you to comment
If he wants to storm it,
if he wants to store
material in a box in a bathroom,
if he wants to store it
in a box on a stage, he can do that.
That is that that is just what
the law and the standard is.
So, again, I think this just underscores
how political this whole thing is.
President Trump
will have his day in court,
but espionage charges
are absolutely ridiculous.
Whether you like Trump or not,
he did not commit espionage.
He did not disseminate
link or provide
information to a foreign power
or a news organization
to damage this country.
He is not a spy.
Congressman, you heard Lindsey Graham
there say that Donald Trump is not a spy.
What was your reaction to all this?
What some of your Republican colleagues
are saying up on the Hill
A federal
indictment is serious
and it should be taken seriously.
And let's be clear
when we think about it, Congressman, or
even a former president,
no one should be above the law.
What I believe is
important is to allow the facts
to continue
to come forth through a process here.
And let's allow the Department of Justice
to continue to do its work.
And as more
facts are made available to the public,
I believe will be at a better place to
better understand what is taking place.
And, Congressman,
let me just get a quick reaction from you
to what
Trump has been saying over the weekend.
He's been calling the special counsel
deranged.
It sounds like he's trying to whip up his
supporters all over again.
He was in your state over the weekend.
Are you concerned about some of this
some of this rhetoric he's been using
The facts are the facts.
And I believe as we apply the facts
to the rule of law
and then
as the American
people are made aware of that,
I believe that's going to be important
in this process.
And also equally important is due process
and allowing a lady justice
to continue to be blind.
And let's
see what comes based on the facts
of the case.
And a CBS poll
that just came out
today seems to suggest
that many Republican voters
see these charges
as just political shows,
that just 7% of Republican voters
have a worse view of Trump
after the indictment.
61% say
the indictment won't change their views.
You heard in the report from
our colleague
Isabel Rosa, a few moments ago,
you know, a lot of Trump supporters
just aren't going to change their mind
based on all of this.
I know what you're saying.
You're saying that people should
look at the facts of this case,
but it sounds like
people have already made up their minds,
at least Trump supporters
have already made up
their minds about this.
They're just not going to change
their view on this.
How did Democrat ads counter that?
Jim, we're still early in this process.
And as the process and polls,
I truly believe more facts will come out
more information
will be made readily available
for the American people.
And as we gain insight to what exactly
those facts are
and how they are applied
towards the rule of law,
that's going to better inform our voters
potentially of what's taking place.
And I have confidence and
faith in the American people.
And President Biden
visited your district on Friday.
He was touting his economic agenda,
pledging support to military families
North Carolina has been a key swing state
in the past, not so much,
maybe in recent elections.
But do you think President Biden
could win
North Carolina in 20, 24, as Barack
Obama did in 2008
North Carolina is always
based in recent history
and very competitive state.
What we are concerned with
especially the families
in eastern North Carolina
or district that I represent,
are those who are able to deliver.
And I must admit,
I haven't agreed with the president.
100%.
But let's look at the Corps.
I hear from families.
They are concerned about jobs.
They're concerned about a strong economy,
our workforce and education.
And when we look at this president
on those issues,
I'm reminded of a bipartisan chips and
infrastructure bill.
And the president,
while he was here in Rocky
Mountain, North Carolina,
the last time the president was here
in Rocky Mountain, North
Carolina, was LBJ in 64.
And the president showed up.
And I can tell you,
being a part of the motorcade
and people
were holding up
the American flag and signs
they received this president very well.
And we went on to Fort Liberty
and the troops there
and their families
embraced this president.
And I want to ask you,
I'm sure you've heard this
in recent days, Democratic Senator Joe
Manchin of West Virginia has kind of
flirted with the possibility
that he might run
for president in 20, 24 might challenge
President Biden,
perhaps on the Democratic side,
there's been some talk
that maybe
there could be some sort of third party
run that might involve Senator Manchin.
What is your sense of all that?
Would that be healthy
for the Democratic Party
if Joe Manchin were to jump into this
candidate?
At the end of the
day, we all have an opportunity
in this democratic process
to come forward.
But again, I went back towards
one of those deliverables,
those things
that people are concerned
about, Eastern North Carolinians,
what they talked about
at the dinner table.
And I do believe that President Biden,
even though, again,
we haven't always agreed,
he has delivered.
Matter of fact,
we always hear
do you think President Biden
should have any chance?
Do you mind if I just jump?
Do you think President Biden
should have any challengers
or do you think he should run unopposed
on the Democrats?
I believe in a Democrat.
I believe in the Democratic process.
And I believe
the American people in the end
will deliver for those who deliver
for them.
All right.
Congressman Don Davis,
thanks very much for your time.
We appreciate it.
Thanks, Joe.